Chris how are you this morning I'm good
I don't know what I was just listening
to but I'm good
well you're not alone because we were
there last night in the moment at
Caroline's when Fritzi took the stage
I've been to Caroline's a few times in
my life I I think I can safely say I'm
glad I wasn't there last night based on
what I deserved all right assess what
happened last night and if you're a
Celtics fan how should you feels this
series goes back to Boston well two
things changed significantly in his last
two games you know one Cleveland won the
physical battle and you know tyloo kind
of said it after Game two that we've got
to be more physical
Boston's kind of gooning it up a little
bit and the Cavaliers these last two
games took that to heart and and they
played more physical but the obvious
number to look at is the rebounding edge
that they won by double digits for the
second game in a row but you know
anecdotally just see Tristan Thompson
and Kevin Love really asserting
themselves over these last two games the
other part of it I saw was you know Brad
Stevens a great coach but I thought
tyloo had a terrific two games
strategically some of the things he did
he noted that Jalen Brown was killing
them in the first quarter he went and he
dispatched LeBron on him early and shut
Braun down twice brown really had a
nightmarish last couple of games that
was a big part of it and you know
sticking Thompson on on Al Horford
throughout the game and if you watched
last night then you know Thompson was
basically on a yo-yo
whenever Horford was in gear came
Tristan Thompson and you know Orford
really struggled you know for these last
two games so you know that was a great
run for Cleveland but one thing about
boss you asked like how the Celtics
should feel how a Boston fan should feel
for whatever reason they're a completely
different team on their own at home
they're a young team and I think that
plays into it young teams really
struggle on the road historically and so
I don't think they're out of it I just
think they have to address the fact that
for two games they were bullied around
the floor what do you make of LeBron
James maybe the best playoff run that
he's ever had
I mean he's he's unreal I mean I've
heard about this last night
you know Boston is a very smart
defensive team and they switch
everything and they communicate really
well a lot of things people necessarily
don't see on TV players will tell me
that that boss is really good at and
LeBron I think he's great is strike then
outside of the muscle and the speed and
the just the ability to pass like a
point guard it's his ability to kind of
diagnose what a defense is doing and
come up with a counter to it and you
know last night you know Boston didn't
want to switch terrorists you're on to
LeBron every single time but you know
throughout the course of the game LeBron
found the man that Rozier was guarding
and and when Adam enforced those
switches those switches absolutely
killed Boston in this one so you know
he's you know look you can point to that
the threes he's on a good streak over
these last deal four games or so that's
huge for his game and everything else
but I just you know it's really amazing
to watch kind of his mind work you know
during the game as he sees a great
defense a really good defense anyway and
just picked it apart talking to Chris
Mannix from Yahoo Sports joining a stand
Patrick show yeah just trying to figure
this out we're Brad Stephen is he still
genius yeah he's still a great coach I
know but people are relying I am a
genius which they shouldn't but even
that's what we do dan there's no way
like we would kind of build them up to
tear him down it's like you know we we
every what Brad Stevens was never quite
as good as ever he said he was and you
know these last couple of games he's not
as bad as some people might think he is
or I just I think you know Game three
there were there was nothing stopping
what Cleveland was doing I mean they
were a juggernaut in Game three I mean
you know they were going a Gershon
llaves le in the first quarter dusting
off Greg Monroe in the first quarter
nothing could stop what Cleveland did I
thought last night there were some
tactical mistakes I would have probably
played Aron Baynes Moore he's really the
only guy that can physically match up
with Tristan Thompson and I thought he
had some good runs you know during that
game and you got to find a way to get
Jason Tatum going
I mean Tatum is Boston's best offensive
player hands down he just he's ability
to score supersedes everybody on that
team but you're seeing what happens to a
twenty-year-old in a physical playoff
series Jason Tatum's got what three
inches on JR Smith
and if you watch him out there Dan off
the ball he can't establish position at
all he he's playing like a
twenty-year-old in this series and Brad
Stevens in the South has got to find
some way to shake that out what I don't
understand is when a team wins by 30 and
then loses by 30 in the next game like
what happens I know that that that we're
changing the site the location but how
does one team go from being so good to
so bad from one game to another well as
I said in Boston's case you know there's
young players are just they're having
trouble on the road not just this series
all postseason they've had trouble in
the road on the flip side of it I don't
have the numbers in front of me but you
can look him up the the Cavs role
players play so much better at home they
do on the road I mean Jerry Smith who
was a streaky as they get his home road
numbers he's just so much better there
Kyle Korver he's been great a lot of
places but he's been better at home I
mean those its perimeter shooting you
know the Cavs are their offense is
predicated on guys making shots around
LeBron James and for whatever reason
there's far more comfortable playing at
home so I think I just think it it boils
down to to that that that these guys
that are younger of or stretchier are
better at home or worse on the road who
do you like you know it's hard to bet
against LeBron when he's got some
momentum but I do think that the use of
Boston it they were they benefit from it
it's feeding off that home crowd and you
know people sometimes think that's
cliche like wow they they feed up the
crowd and all that stuff and the players
tend to sound kind of dumb when they say
like it our home crowds the best in the
NBA but the simple fact is that you know
all postseason the Celtics have just
been a different team at home and they
still only have to win their home games
down the stretch that being said I mean
this is this is the greatest player of
our generation who has you know figured
some things out about the way the
Celtics are defending him and as I wrote
last night dandy that the Celtics are
just another team that LeBron is in a
position to own I mean think about the
teams that LeBron is decimated over
these last seven years
I mean Indiana versions of it the
Atlanta Hawks when boot nose was
coaching that
there's four all-stars and now the
Celtics we're in the position now to
potentially be for the third time in the
playoffs in four years this guy is is a
one-man wrecking ball in the Eastern
Conference so it's hard to bet against
them
those aren't exactly murderers row the
team's you're telling me about that well
no but but Indiana was was really good
when when Paul George and West River
were there right they mean competitors
for 60 win team 61 team with four
all-stars on it you know one of those
years down I mean they were like me not
you know it's not Golden State or
Houston I'll give you that but how
important is this game tonight what we
we both know I need boss to win because
I'm already terrified of losing my hair
so that's that's the biggest factor in
all this now here's the thing if if that
happens you need to get your hair buzzed
on the show prior to the start of the
NBA Finals no that was never part of
that was never part of the bet that you
Paulie do you have the paperwork there
got it right here J no clause about that
yeah there's no clause about waiting
till after the NBA Finals Mannix there's
also no clause that says they have to do
with the force no you Pampa been right
you do no I mean that's what gentlemen
no no I'm agreeing like like like Samson
in the Bible I'm agreeing to have my no
no no no Chris well well sure Mannix I'd
like to point out that your right-hand
man their folly swore to me that you
would never fulfill your end of the
bargain on this one loud to me that
you'd never let me host the show with
you there I guarantee because it's not
gonna happen Dan will make a sermon how
do you think you got those strange calls
last night that when against the Celtics
hello
bad calls both ways though I just didn't
like the way it was officiated alright
I'll leave you with this
how important is tonight for the Rockets
now it's everything especially if big
Madonna is not able to play I'm
you've got to pull something out I mean
nobody can beat golden state like in
back-to-back games it's almost
impossible I mean the idea that any team
even a team that won 65 games can do it
in three out of four is just completely
impossible I mean look more than
anything dad this game is a referendum
on James Harden you know James Harden is
the probable MVP he was completely
outplayed by a bunch of guys most
notably Steph Curry in in Game three I
mean this this is the game that I think
James Harden is gonna remember for years
if he shows up in the Rockets win it's
gonna be a feather in his cap but if he
know so much like he did in Game three
we're gonna be talking about this and
hardens in ability to win the playoffs
for a long time thank you Chris
you got it Dan that's Chris Mannix Yahoo
Sports his bed is if Boston doesn't go
to the NBA Finals then he will get his
hair cut off a buzz cut and then I think
it's something like if Boston does go
then he gets to host the show while I'm
in McLovin seat is that what it is
Paulie or you guys know yeah I guess you
have to sit elsewhere get to your chair
so I just observe right observe and
report
you're like the fit Dan out with us yes
14 so we gonna roll with that new
nickname Chris the well Germanic so it
hasn't been nice ring to it yeah pending
on how things I mean when you lose a bet
you pay the bet you don't go let me wait
until it's convenient he wants to delay
it for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]